about the the princes which ones both of
them uh william and harry oh you met the
okay all right and then all they want to
know is when is the friends reunion
that's all they wanted to know about
would you tell them
if there were some single guys here in
the uk
would you be interested in a british guy
judging by
no no
no
who's your favorite wu-tang clan member
you speak english
you don't know the rap group the wu-tang
clan with the rhythm the jesus
method
you're so good in zombieland
i must be mellowing with age but i want
to say this very clearly the next time
i'm not asked the first questions
[Applause]
are you worried about mayweather
it well to me it's it's warmer in july
so i'm not really worried about the
mayweather you know you stole a tv dog
from b-e-t
so you know what this was around the
time when bt wasn't playing my videos
and they was
they was acting real funny so
i had to send a message to the top and
let them know i wasn't playing
what
those guys are basically entertainers
and they admit that you're an
entertainer somewhat what are you saying
somewhat no we're informational driven
we give information
really interested
in learning english right now
[Music]
please tell me
what your favorite what eat
supercalifragilisticexpialidocious
anything you want to confess before you
go
um i got my ass out there we go so there
you go well thank you guys thank you for
blessing thank you for having me
so when did you first get into bikes
oh yeah okay well when i was a kid i
think i was eight yeah i was walking to
school and i saw a guy get hit by a car
on his motorcycle
and he flew off the bike yeah and his
helmet flew off yeah and i had my
backpack and i walked up to him and i
was right above him he had this long
blonde hair
and all this blood started pouring out
from behind his head
and i looked down and he looked up at me
and saw this little kid i don't think if
he knew whether he was in heaven or hell
and then and i thought my first thing i
thought was i gotta get a motorcycle
yeah
i also happen to call him a lightweight
okay and i have said that so i would
like to take that back he's really not
that much of a lightweight he hit my
hands nobody has ever hit my hands i've
never heard of this one look at those
hands are they small hands
and he referred to my hands if they're
small something else must be small i
guarantee you there's no problem i
guarantee this movie i can't even begin
to tell you how much i love this film it
was uh it's entertaining it's
thought-provoking it's a melancholy it's
funny it's just a really it's the total
package
go on
[Laughter]
and you get to be with the pretty boy
george clooney yeah he's all right he
actually i sat him down
when we were shooting i sat him down and
i tried to pick his brain about how to
give a really good interview and i swear
apropos of nothing he was like well if
you ever do letterman and in my mind i'm
like yeah okay george when i go on david
letterman but um but he was like uh he
was like just be really really nice and
if he gives you a hard time just keep
complimenting him so
i had to get high
i had to back i had to get hurt
um i couldn't handle it
you have to go enough you understand me
thank you
thank you
[Music]
you want to take this stuff off
when you first got here i was like oh we
got to have this guy on the show and
then i saw
i was looking in the la times and you
took out
an advertiser
a lot of athletes will take out a
full-page ad usually when they leave
they thank the city you know for
everything but you took one out um to as
you just as you got started and it says
dear los angeles you're welcome
how big is 50 cent's penis
this is him right before he wakes up
and then you're like is that gonna get
bigger
and then it does
what's the one thing that would surprise
us about dwayne johnson
um he's 90 cgi
you know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's time at the first debate we had
millions of people uh fact-checking so i
expect we'll have millions more
fact-checking uh because you know it is
uh
it's just awfully good that someone
with the temperament of donald trump is
not in charge of the law in our country
because you'd be in jail secretary
clinton
now last time you were here you
proclaimed rather proudly that you had
kicked pot marijuana you had stopped
completely how's that going for you it
kicked me back
[Applause]
season after season what what drives you
to do it
uh the paycheck
pretty much the money my kind of guy
matt leblanc crazy bestseller how many
weeks have been on the bestseller six
months on investing
here's what breaks my heart about this
because in my mind i think of you as a
goon
and but then when you look at
look at this picture look at how sweet
and adorable that kid is and it breaks
my heart because i have a sweet adorable
kid like that and i think oh great what
if he too becomes a goon
now i remember last time you were here
there was you were with justin bieber
and i was with a justin bieber
yeah you were with a justin bieber
and and is that that's not going on now
no i'm single yeah yeah you're fine so
good good yeah now the last time he was
on uh he and i got into a conversation
and i he said something and i said
something and then he said something and
i said something
and i made him cry
[Laughter]
well then that makes two of us
wow
this is your advice to young actors to
check out more asses or whatever yeah i
would say that's a good way to get going
the matlab black school
of acting
we have you instagrammed a picture of
you with beyonce and you did you you put
this heart around it no that was just
there
oh no